(man) the sharks are back.
And they're looking
for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that really
matters--What is it? Money.
Hopeful entrepreneurs
come to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
What do we get?
This ask is excluding
the publishing.
(Kevin and mark) Oh.
I think it's foolish.
(Kevin) Are you crazy?
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
I have to say,
I love your little package.
You're 5% apart.
Are you out of your mind?
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm gonna stick
to the $200,000.
That's a stupid--
That's a mistake.
What a creep.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I'm a dreamer like everybody
here was a dreamer.
No, no. It's a Hobby.
(singsongy)
Shoulders, shoulders, down.
Whassup?
I see you workin' it.
Who are the sharks?
They're five powerful,
self-Made investors
worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-Filled city
of manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
First into the tank
are Erika Welsh
and Keeley Tillotson,
college students
with a business they created
in their dorm room.
Hi, I'm Keeley.
And I'm Erika.
We founded our company
wild squirrel nut butter
This January as sophomores
at the university of oregon.
Wild squirrel is seeking
a $50,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Keeley and I
lovepeanut butter.
In fact,
we love peanut Butter So much
that one rainy Friday afternoon
in our college apartment,
as we were scraping the bottom
of yet another jar
of generic peanut butter,
we realized that we had
a brand-New food processor
and a bag of peanuts.
So it wasn't long
before we had created
our first batch
of homemade peanut butter.
Since Erika and I both really
enjoyed creating recipes,
we started adding
New Ingredients
from around our house.
We soon had come up
with four exciting flavors
andwaymore peanut butter
than we knew what to do with.
So we started passing it out
to our friends around campus.
Today we wanted you all to have
the same opportunity.
Any one?
Yep.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you, Erika.
(Keeley) So we have
four flavors.
We have sneaky cinnamon,
which is our cinnamon raisin,
bright eyed & bushy tailed,
which is our chocolate espresso
peanut butter,
curious cocoa-Nut, which is our
chocolate coconut peanut butter,
and we have pretzel pizzaz,
our honey pretzel peanut butter.
It's good.
(Barbara) Wow.
It's very good.
The pretzel's great.
That's awesome.
That cinnamon's great.
The, uh, the pretzel
is fantastic.
(woman) Good.
(daymond) Very good.
Try the cinnamon.
To date, we have sold thousands
of jars of our peanut butter
on our web site,
at farmers' markets,
and at campus street fairs.
In the next month,
we'll be on shelves
at grocery stores
throughout oregon.
And we're confident
that with the right funding,
wild squirrel Peanut butter
can become a national brand.
So you sold thousands...
in what time period
and how many?
We have been selling
since february,
and we've sold 3,500 jars.
How many dollars
have you sold?
We have, uh, gross--$14,000
and profited $7,000.
What's the peanut butter
sell for?
We make them for $3 and sell
them to the stores for $4.
And they retail for $5.99.
So you only make $1 of profit
per--Per jar?
Right now. Since we're just
beginning, we haven't found
the perfect sourcing
for all of our products yet.
Tell me about you guys first
before we get too far
into the details.
What year in school--You said
you're sophomores still or--
We're about to be juniors.
You're about to be juniors.
At the university
of oregon.
What are you majoring in?
I am an environmental studies
and spanish major.
I'm journalism and art.
So we kind of fell into this.
We call it our honorary
business major. (laughs)
What kind of help have you
gotten from the outside
and do you 2 each own 50%,
or who else is involved?
Right now, we each own 50%.
My parents have backed us
for $50,000.
Why do you need our $50,000?
They're little
peanut butter monsters.
We need $50,000
because the $50,000
we're getting from her parents
will only cover
the first run.
Ladies, just a quick question
about your business model,
because we're selling them
for $4 a unit.
The cost to make them is $3.
The profit's only $1.
You have to reverse that.
You have to make it for $1
and make $3.
Well, the bigger the run
we do with the co-Packer,
the less it costs
per jar.
How big does it have to be
that I could make $3
on every one that you sell
instead of $1?
We can cut--I-I'm confident
we could cut our cost
by $1 a jar.
By $1 to $2.
No. I want you to cut
your cost by $3.
We c--I'm--I'm sure
we could do it.
I'm confident
(Barbara) Meanwhile,
how are you balancing that?
How do you remain a student,
an inventor, a businessperson,
and do it all at once?
We--
Well, the great thing about
being in college
is we have so many resources.
We have an incredible
entrepreneurship program
that's helped us a lot.
So far
college has helped us.
What I'm concerned with is,
is who's gonna run it?
I mean, there are--There are
very successful people--
Bill gates, Steve jobs--
Who quit university because they
started their business
and said, "Hey, this is better.
I'm learning more running this
business than I am at school."
And we've said that
a million times.
And I think we're going
to fall term classes,
and we're gonna feel it out
and see what's happening.
So, Keeley and Erika,
so great peanut butter.
Thank you. (laughs)
I love your energy.
But, you know, being new
to this space,
I can't learn this business
with you.
I need my money to work for me
and not me working for my money.
Okay.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
So, ladies,
let's get down to business.
(laughs)
Um, you've said that
you will
sell me 10% of this company
for $50,000.
So you're valuing
the company today
at half a million dollars.
Do you see any problem
with that?
Nope.
Our value's in future sales,
not in present sales.
But you want me to pay
for the future now.
Right. That's what
you have to do. (laughs)
(Robert) Look, it--
Here's the difference between
going to school
and the real world.
In the real world,
when you fail,
you don't get a bad grade
from your professor
and go to another class
the next day.
You lose money.
Somebody needs to
do this full-Time,
otherwise it's a Hobby.
So who is gonna do it
full-Time tomorrow
if I give you my money?
We believe that
with both of us working,
that equates to one person.
We are--
(mark) That doesn't count, guys.
That doesn't count.
Because there's somebody
out there competing with you
that's trying to kick your ass,
and they're not going--
They're not going to class
saying "Two equals one."
And because I know that
it's gonna be
a huge amount of work,
I have to say, I'm out.
We are determined
to succeed.
We are both
extremely hard workers.
We are dedicated.
We put our time into things
and we make--
We wake up at 5:00
every morning--
We see the results.
I believe you're motivated,
but I think what everybody sees
as a major fault is,
in the competitive world
of peanut butter,
there are teams like you that
get up at 5:00 in the morning
and work till 10:00 at night
to keep that shelf space
and to grow it.
Look, girls, this--
Or 12 hours...
(Robert) 10 hours a day?
What is it, a vacation?
Or 20 hours a day.
20.
This--This is--
We can still
spend that time.
Yeah, but wait a second.
This is the cold reality
of business.
When I see you again,
you're gonna be a lot older.
I know that because
the world is gonna kick
the living crap out of you.
(laughs)
Don't listen to--
and that is not a bad thing.
That is not a bad thing.
I know the world of hurt
you're gonna go into
when you start retailing
peanut butter.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Erika and Keeley only have
two more chances
to get a deal.
We have never cared
about anything
as much
as this peanut butter.
We want to work with you guys
so bad.
You guys have
so much to offer us.
And I think we could make this
a national brand.
And that's what we plan to do,
and we would love
to have your help.
Well, I just want to say
12 credits of class
is 12 hours a week.
I can spend
the rest of the hours
working on peanut butter,
and we have.
We have.
Our company's value is
the--the value the way it is
because it deserves it
and because we deserve it.
And we've worked really hard
and we will continue
to work hard.
N-N-No,
no, Keeley.
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
Life doesn't work that way.
You don't get in life
what you deserve.
You get in life
what you make of it.
Valuing your company
because you're good people,
you deserve it, is almost
like expecting a Bull
not to attack you
'cause you're a vegetarian.
(laughter)
Yes, we understand.
It's not gonna work.
(Robert) It's focus,
it's dedication,
it's all that stuff, and I think
you're gonna get there.
But you're not there yet.
For that reason...
uh, I'm out.
Barbara. (laughs)
(chuckles)
(Kevin) Barbara,
please, before you start,
that little squirrel
is going to be a rodent
with rabies to you...
(laughs)
If you give these girls
$50,000.
Who's saying
I'm giving them money?
All right.
Mind your business.
You're out.
You know, I could argue
either side, I have to tell you.
'cause I own now
three businesses
as a result of "Shark tank"
in the food area.
Mm-hmm.
So I've had--
I've had very good success,
but you know
what has surprised me?
The amount of money that it has
taken to make a success of that,
and it sure was a Heck of a lot
more than $50,000.
So I think it's foolish
that you come in here
and ask for $50,000
just to take care
of the next stage,
and that worries me.
You know what?
(Kevin speaks indistinctly)
I'll give you an offer,
but I hope I don't regret it.
I'm counting on you.
But bear in mind,
when I give it to you,
it's with an EYE toward really
knowing what's gonna be needed
down the road--
Six months out,
a year out--
When you have a huge success.
My Daisy Cake Business
went from
$10,000 a year
to $150,000 a month.
Okay.
That's a lot of product
to fund.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm gonna give you an offer
of your $50,000
for 40%.
You want to think about that?
35%. We'd be happy
with 35%.
35% is not enough.
♪♪♪
(Kevin)
there's only one offer,
and you're 5% apart.
Are you out of your minds?
(Barbara) This isn't
just about the money.
This is about access.
Barbara,
we would love
to accept your offer.
Great. And I'm gonna
make you rich.
Whoo.
Thank you.
Great.
(mark) Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations.
We're looking forward
to working with you.
My pleasure.
Thanks for taking
a chance on us.
You're terrific.
(both) Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
♪♪♪
(Keeley)
She has so much expertise
and she's gonna really take
our business to the next level
and we're just--
We're thrilled right now.
We're out--
Psyched out of our mind.
♪♪♪
Earlier this season, we watched
Steve gadlin strike a deal
with mark Cuban
for an online company called...
I get it.
I love your creativity.
'cause I'm invested in you.
You got a deal.
Done!
What?!
hit it.
♪♪♪
(daymond) to the side.
To the side.
(sharks laugh)
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Ever since I made a deal
with mark cuban on "Shark tank,"
my life has been
absolutely ridiculous.
Last year my sales
Were only $7,000.
In the weeks
after "Shark tank,"
my sales are already
over $40,000,
and my business has increased
almost 3,000%.
That's... freakin' crazy.
♪♪♪
In order to keep up with all of
the demand, I've had to grow.
I have an office space now
and I've picked up
some employees.
I've got people helping me
with the coloring work
and with all the mailing.
How many hours
are we at today?
14.
Keep going. Keep going.
I've written three checks
to mark cuban
on this investment already.
He's making a return.
So if you see him walking around
in fancy new threads,
know that's his
cat drawing dough, okay?
That's from me.
Thanks to mark's investment,
I've been able
to launch several new projects.
I've launched I want
to write a song for you,
where we will write you
a personal theme song
for just $99.95.
I've got all these ideas,
and now I have the backing
and the support
to actually follow through
with them.
I think the real lesson here
is that
you can make money doing
whatever makesyouvery happy.
Come on, guys. Do this.
♪ Do do, do do, do do do ♪
that's way freakin' cool,
dudes.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is cab20
with a proposal of a band
as a business investment.
♪♪♪
Hi, my name's Tom Callahan.
I represent cab 20,
the brainchild of 18-year-Old
music prodigy Bert Hoover.
Uh, we're seeking an investment
of $200,000
for a 20% equity position
in this band.
When I first met this band
about six months ago,
I saw this huge potential
and was impressed
by their talent.
Cab 20 has that "it,"
if you will.
So I'd like to present to you
the band cab 20.
(playing "Stomp")
♪ I've been waitin'
for a while now ♪
♪ to hear your name ♪
♪ you set your heart
and you set your soul ♪
♪ the feeling still remains ♪
♪ she said,
I don't need no notion ♪
♪ I will disappear ♪
♪ won't be gone
for too long ♪
♪ but I'm gettin' outta here ♪
♪ tonight ♪
♪ what if her love ♪
♪ burns like the sun? ♪
♪ You don't got none
unless you got some ♪
♪ of her ♪
(cheering)
Good job, guys.
Yeah.
Outstanding.
Wow.
So tell us about
what's included.
What do we get?
Primarily publishing,
merchandising, and touring.
Right.
And there's also, of course
record sales, digital downloads.
There's
tv/film placement.
There's lots of things,
but this, uh, ask
is excluding the publishing.
Oh.
See, that was gonna be
my question--Is this a 360 deal?
Well, most of 360 deals
actually don't include
the publishing.
It's usually
an--An added negotiation.
(Robert) Tom, explain to me
how the deal works.
I'm not as familiar
as these guys.
(mark) Yeah, let me.
You--
Robert, what basically--
360 means
it covers everything.
So your touring,
your music sales.
So what he's saying, it includes
all their revenues
except for publishing,
which is the, um,
any revenue received
because they've written songs.
(Kevin) I mean, come on.
Publishing's what this
is all about.
If these guys are huge
20 years from now,
I want the revenue stream.
I want to wet my beak
in that, too.
Unless you want to throw
some more money in the pot,
and we can talk about that,
but... (chuckles)
So, Bert, who would you be
most comparable to today?
We always get comparisons
to, like, the black keys,
white stripes.
Love white Stripes.
What do you bring
to the table?
I've worked in So many
different capacities
over the 25 years--
Major label, consulting,
promotion and marketing--
Everybody from Lenny kravitz
to shania twain. Um...
you managed Lenny kravitz?
No, this is promotion
and marketing areas, yes.
Is this
your first entire band
that you're gonna spearhead
from conception
all the way through?
Yes.
But we're investing as much
in you as we are the band.
Yeah,
I would think so.
(Kevin) the percentage of bands
that break out
and make a lot of money
for their investors is,
as you know,
very, very small.
(mark)
Look, the music business
is the worst business
on the planet.
It scares
the hell outta me.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
(daymond) I did a deal
with universal Music
about eight years ago,
and by the time I was done
investing in that music,
I was out of $6 million
for one album.
Good thing is, I ended up having
a song called "Fatty girl,"
and I made $100 million
off the clothes,
But if it wasn't for that,
I would've been demolished.
Well, the--the--
Well, as I was saying,
(daymond speaks indistinctly)
the publishing is where
you make the money...
one--One second.
The touring is where
you make the money.
One second.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
You know, I have to say, I love
your little package here.
I like Bert.
He looks like a virgin.
And the girls are gonna
go nuts for him.
Then you got your--
(Kevin) Wow.
You got a groupie.
Then you got your John Lennon
lookalike guy.
And then you got a guy
who needs a bath.
Now the three together--
Slash. It's slash.
It's not--Yeah.
(Kevin, daymond,
and Robert laughing)
So I like it, you know.
It feels real to me.
But, you know,
you don't feel to me,
in my bones, like a guy
that could hustle,
break through doors.
I want tofeel youcoming
at me,
and I don't get that.
So even if I loved the band,
I wouldn't buy into you.
I'm out.
Fair enough.
♪♪♪
It's okay.
Are you an aggressive guy?
I'm a martial artist
in kyokushin karate,
third Dan.
Whoa.
(Robert) Black belt.
This guy is serious. Why didn't
you bring that out earlier?
That says a certain discipline.
Barbara, you're wrong
about this guy.
No, I'm not.
Anybody who can get
a black belt like that...
I hope I'm wrong.
(Kevin) the band's good.
I like their music.
I'll make you an offer
just for the hell of it,
'cause that's the business
you're in.
You're in the crapshoot-
Who-the-hell-Knows business.
I'll give you 200k for 50%
ofeverything,
'cause I could lose $200,000
in the next 6 months with you,
no problem.
That's the deal.
I've always wanted to have
a rock band in my portfolio.
I know
it's a stupid investment,
but it's cool,
and I am not gonna run
the band,
I'm not gonna
get in your way,
I'm not gonna tell you
what songs to write.
I'm giving you $200,000.
I want 50%.
Yeah. I-I mean, for $300,000
I'd go up to 40%.
I'm not there.
You'll do $300,000
for 40%?
For 40%.
That's your counter
to Kevin?
This is a crapshoot.
So for me,
it's a vanity play.
I'm a Boring
old computer guy.
Speak for yourself.
Deep down, I want to be
a rock star.
I'll throw some money in.
You want to join me?
Go 50/50.
I'll go 50/50.
You got a deal.
Um, do I--could I talk
to the band for a bit?
(mark) Sure.
Is that okay?
Yeah. Feel free.
Why don't you go ahead and take
'em back in the hallway? Yeah.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
I'm gonna rename the band
greed. (laughs)
(Robert)
I like the name greed.
Greed of love.
Um, what do you want to do?
It's up to you.
Should we do--Should we do,
uh, $250,000?
Yeah.
I think so.
As long as we have control--
Let's try to get--
Let's try and get $250,000--
And if not then--
And d-don't worry about
the control.
They're not gonna touch that.
Okay.
They're good. They're good.
They're good.
Well, they're good...
they are good.
But there's
a million good bands.
There's a lot of good bands.
All right. So what do you
have to say?
We were hoping we can get
$250,000 for the 50%.
And we could shake hands today
and move forward.
I have to check
with my partner here.
Robert, you would be cool again
with your daughter.
Here's your chance.
My daughter loves me, mark,
even without $200,000.
I'm gonna stick
to the $200,000.
Oh, what a creep.
And I feel the same way.
We're stuck at that number.
That's the deal--
$200,000, 50%,
and I hope you hit.
I'm very confident
with the band.
And I've seen bands
make millions
and millions of dollars
that I've been involved with.
We can't do it. I'm sorry.
Why?
I know what these guys
are capable of.
Okay, rename the band
you're dead to me.
(laughs)
(Robert laughs)
I appreciate your time...
(daymond) All right.
Very much.
Thanks, guys.
You guys are good.
That's what's important.
(Barbara) Good luck.
(Robert) Good luck to you.
Thank you. Thank you.
Great music.
In several years,
when these guys
are playing Arenas
and playing around the world,
the sharks, you know,
they're gonna regret it.
Their loss.
Definitely.
♪♪♪
Next up are Frank scozzafava
and Adam disilvestro
who believe they have
the next big trend in Swimwear.
Hello, my name is Frank.
And I'm Adam.
The name of our business
is mix bikini,
and we are seeking $50,000
in exchange for 5%
of our business.
It's no secret
women love to stand out.
But there is nothing worse
for a woman
than being at the beach
and seeing another girl
in the same bikini,
and that's the reason
we created mix bikini.
♪♪♪
Mix bikini is the world's
first interchangeable swimsuit.
All the parts of mix bikini
are sold separately,
and all the parts--they
interchange with one another.
The more bikini parts
a girl collects,
the more bikini designs
she can create.
So if you go here to mix bikini,
you can see how we make one.
You start out
by picking your top,
you pick either a Halter top
or a triangle top.
Then you pick different prints,
you pick different colors,
then you pick the back.
And then you can also pick
rings and strings.
And the next day, the bikini is
shipped out right to your door.
But now the best part is,
when a girl decides
to "mix it up,"
she doesn't need to buy
a whole new bikini.
She just purchases
any New additional piece
she wants to add
to her collection.
So for instance here,
she switches out her left top
and her back bottom.
Giving her a whole new look.
And there is nothing like
mix bikini on the market.
So we ask you,
which one of you sharks
wanna swim with mix bikini?
How many have you sold?
Um, we haven't sold that many.
We--We're just launched,
a soft launch.
So your sales are zero?
Not zero, But, uh,
very minimal.
By the way, you didn't say
what that sells for.
Do you mind my asking
what it sells for?
So every part retails
for $9.99.
The entire bikini
would cost ya,
depending on
which one you made,
between $40 and $50 to create,
which is very reasonable.
And is your intention
to sell it online period?
No, no.
We'd like to open up a kiosk
so that when girls
walk through a mall,
they can really get to touch
and play and feel
and design it--
and what's the cost
of one kiosk?
The cost of actually
building the kiosk
would cost us about $25,000
to build the freestanding kiosk.
Negotiating the rent, that's
a--that's a whole nother story.
We didn't ask about
a bigger topic here.
You're asking $50,000 for 5%.
That means that you're saying
the company
is valued at $1 million.
Yes.
It was 10%
we were asking.
I'm sorry $50,000
for 10%?
Correct.
So half a million dollars.
No. You know, you asked
for $50,000 for 5%.
You guys
talk to each other?
(Robert)
Yeah, which one is it?
It's 10%, $50,000.
(daymond) Okay,
so half a million dollars
you're saying your company
is worth at this moment,
and you haven't made
not one sale.
(Kevin) I'm just trying
to understand
what the business model is.
Don't you just want
to license this to people?
Maybe I do want to license
it to somebody. I'm not sure.
There are so many ways
we can go with this.
Well, pick one.
We don't know. We're here.
We're--We're--We're open
to suggestions.
(mark) When you come into
the shark tank,
you have to have a business.
We can offer capital,
we can offer guidance,
but we can't set the path
for you, right?
What you guys have
is a product and an idea
and a hope.
I'm out.
(Kevin) Frank, Frank,
I wanna make a point to you
that if you've seen other,
um, entrepreneurs here
in the shark tank
walk out with money,
the only guys that ever,
ever get any money
are able to articulate
in 90 seconds,
here's howIget rich.
That's all I care about.
This is how you get rich,
because this is gonna--
Now you're doing it?
Yeah, now I'm doing it.
You want me to do
your presentation for you?
Now I'm doing it.
Every girl that has ever
worn, seen,
touched this bikini
has loved it and wants it.
This bikini is gonna be
the next hottest trend,
and it's a $10-Billion-a-year
industry.
1/10 of 1% will make you more
money than you already have.
Frank, Frank, you talk
so much smack, right?
When you walked in the door,
it was, you know, "kiosk."
$50,000 is not
gonna build a kiosk.
It's not gonna program
the software.
It's not gonna get
all the pieces together.
But we have money.
Okay? We don't have
the expertise.
(Robert) What do you mean,
you have money?
You guys
are asking about money.
We have some money.
How much money do you have
to put into this?
We have as much as $500,000.
So then why are you here?
(Robert) Yeah.
I'm here because,
like you said, daymond,
we need your expertise.
Mark, we need
your publicity that--
that you're so great at doing.
I mean,
your online capabilities.
Barbara, your woman's touch.
I mean, I read a book one time
that said you can either
hang around with chickens
or you can soar with eagles.
We don't want to be
your eagle.
We want to help you
be eagles, right?
And I'm telling you how
we're gonna do it.
And you're not there.
This is
how we're gonna do that.
We're gonna either license this
to a major brand,
we're gonna license it
to more than one major brand,
we're gonna partner up
with an existing brand,
or we can build a brand.
It is not that easy.
Trust me.
If it was, I would be
all over it.
I'm out.
I like to take money--
I've always said,
they're little soldiers.
I like them to send them out
into battle,
take prisoners, come home.
Look, I don't care
if I do it with bikinis
or dog food.
I couldn't care less.
I just want more money.
And I don't understand
with working with you...
(Frank) You--
How I would get there.
You are gonna make more money
because This is the hottest
concept in swimwear.
There's nothing like it
on the market.
All it needs is a little match
to light...
it may be,
but you don't have a--
the gasoline.
It's gonna blow up.
I'm a dreamer like everybody
here was a dreamer,
and I'm going after my dream.
(Robert) Hey,
there's nothing wrong--
Daymond was a dreamer.
You were a dreamer.
There's nothing wrong with--
We were all dreamers--
Barbara--But you know what?
There's nothing wrong
with being a dreamer.
Good. Exactly.
You came out here. You didn't
give us any numbers.
Barbara, you haven't--
You've been pretty quiet.
You haven't said much.
I'd like to hear
a woman's perspective.
What disturbs me is,
you have
so many moving parts
in the product itself.
I can't imagine it
in a retail environment,
'cause I think you actually
have to demonstrate
how you do the darn thing.
But I'll tell you something.
I think this is a business
that could do well.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
♪♪♪
Okay.
I'm gonna give you the $50,000
for 25% of your business.
Okay.
You better say Yes right now
while you got that shot.
Don't--don't let her
change her mind.
♪♪♪
You have a deal, Barbara.
Thank you for believing in us.
I do believe in you.
Thank you
for the woman's touch.
Thank you very much.
(Robert) I didn't see
that one coming, Barbara.
Thank you.
And you gotta take
some speech lessons.
What's with you?
Thank you.
You gotta talk.
Thanks, guys.
Good luck.
Bye-Bye.
(Kevin) Good luck to you.
(Barbara) Bye-Bye.
I like the bulldog tenacity. He
had no business plan whatsoever.
I bet he'll do Well, though.
♪♪♪
My name is Billy Blanks jr.
I'm from los Angeles,
and I've created a program
that revolutionizes
the fitness industry.
5, 6, 7...
(woman) Here we go!
Here we go. Slide.
Slide.
It's a fitness program
that makes fitness fun
for people of all ages,
shapes, and sizes.
When my wife and I
created the program,
we were homeless.
This is the motel
that we actually stayed at.
When we lost our home.
Being here motivated me to go,
"I-I gotta get outta this."
My wife and I
have risked everything
to make this program
come to life.
Right, left. Front, back.
To the right.
Right.
Left.
Front, back. Come on.
I want to prove that I can make
a name for myself on my own.
I've had a lot of hurdles
in life.
To the right side.
Walk 1...
I know that we have
a great idea,
and I need the sharks to help me
bring this idea to the world.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks. My name
is Billy Blanks jr.
And I'm the creator of
"Billy Blanks Jr.'s
dance with me."
I'm here today asking
for $100,000 investment
for a 20% stake in my company.
You know, I grew up
in a fitness family.
My father is Billy Blanks,
the creator of "Tae bo"
And the biggest fitness selling
dvd in history.
But growing up
in a fitness family,
I always felt like it was
a little too serious, you know?
Uh, the boot camp thing--
I wasn't about
screaming in people's face.
I-I danced my whole life
on Broadway,
and I always felt, well,
dancing keeps me in shape.
I have a great time dancing.
Why can't it be fun?
"Billy Blanks Jr.'s
dance with me"
is an all-Inclusive workout
for people of all ages,
shapes, and sizes.
It includes
all styles of dance,
from hip-Hop to bollywood
to line dancing,
to the tango,
to hula dancing, african.
You name it, we do it.
So I want to show you guys what
dance with me is all about,
all right?
I brought my wife and my, uh,
codirector of this program,
Sharon Catherine Blanks,
and I got some students here.
Everyday people, okay?
(up-Tempo music starts)
Now I want you guys to dance
in your seats a little bit
if you can, all right?
Just move with us.
Arms. Yeah.
Like that, Barbara.
I like that.
Come on, Mr. Wonderful.
(laughs)
Just groove with us,
all right?
So the first step,
we're gonna start off
with a little bit of hip-Hop
rowing like this.
Row it out. Come on. Unh!
Now if you're at home,
I want you to get up and dance
with us, too, all right?
Come on. Row it. Yeah.
So this is the row.
We're gonna go hip-Hop style.
Now we're gonna move on
to the next one.
We're gonna go shoulder,
shoulder, down, whassup?
Shoulder, shoulder, down.
Whassup?
(sharks laughing)
Come on, y'all.
Come on.
Shoulder, shoulder, down.
Come on, daymond.
Whassup?
Now double time. Here we go.
Shoulder, shoulder, down.
Whassup?
Come on. Yes. We're gonna move
on to a little bit of disco.
I know Mr. Mark cuban
used to teach disco.
Yeah.
Right? Come on. Come on.
Oh, lord.
Come on. Down here.
Get out there.
Cheer him on, y'all.
Right here.
Whoo! Yes, yes.
Where do you want me?
Go, mark. Go, mark.
Right here. Come on.
I gotta be able to see you.
(Barbara) Go, mark.
Go, mark. Go, mark.
Come on. Come on.
Look at that, huh?
(laughs)
Yeah, give it up for him.
There you go, baby. (laughs)
(music stops)
Thank you, guys.
(mark) Wow.
That's it? Aw.
I think I lost 20 pounds.
(Barbara laughs)
(Robert)
Well, that was fun.
High energy. Whoo.
Thank you very much.
So you know
from the "tae bo" Experience
that it's very expensive
to launch
a product into the market.
I'm assuming that's why you're
here for the $100,000, right?
Actually, I'm here
for my instructor
certification program.
I have dvds--Two dvds
out right now.
They're at all the walmarts,
targets,
best buy,
and with lionsgate.
I have just signed a contract
with them for four more dvds
to come out
in the next two years.
Okay, so let--Let's get
some clarification here.
Those are
your consumer products.
And now you're looking
to create
an INSTRUCTOR certification
program?
So these are two separate
businesses then, right?
It's two separate businesses.
What it is is,
uh, you know, I have--Peop--
The e-mails that I'm getting
are people going, "I've been
working out to the dvds.
Now how do I do
the live class?"
what I'm trying to do
is train the teachers
to teach the workout
so somebody
can do it in New York,
somebody can do it in l.A.
So tell us about
the business model there.
What happens is,
the instructor will come.
They pay 250 bucks.
Uh, they take
the 2-Day course.
And then from there, they're
certified for one year.
But, Billy, how do you scale it?
How do you make it go wide?
When we go to each city,
we select ten master trainers,
that when we leave, they
continue to host certifications.
My goal is to have
a person in every city
by This time next year.
And what's the revenue
of the combined business?
Uh, right now, I don't know.
They just released--
The dvds just released.
You're asking us to invest
in this--
call it
the wholesale business, right?
Mm-hmm.
But you're not giving us
any part of the retail business.
See, if I give you $100,000,
I want you to work your ass off,
you know,
every minute of every day,
so we both get a return
on our investment.
(Robert) Billy, look, for me,
mark hit the nail on the head.
I think the brand is you.
You build one,
you build the other.
They've gotta be combined.
Can you combine it?
Yeah, I would combine 'em.
I would combine 'em, 'cause
to me, it's that important.
If you guys believe in me,
I'm not sitting here
trying to keep everything
in my pocket.
Billy, can you tell me more
about "Tae bo" With your dad?
I was not familiar
with that at all.
Yeah, "Tae Bo," uh, was
something my dad created
that was a karate-Kickboxing
workout.
It's the highest selling
fitness dvd in history.
Did he invest
in your business?
If it's such a big brand,
he should be the biggest
believer in the world.
Very good question.
Uh, you know...
some family structures
are different.
Family structures where
the parents make money
and the parents share
that wealth with their family.
Then there--
So he's a cheapskate?
(laughs) That's--
Well, I would--
or he's making you earn it.
He's making me earn it.
(Barbara)
So without his backup,
how have you made that work
by yourself?
Uh, well, my wife, who was
dancing here with me today,
uh, she's been
a support system.
And also, you know, for me,
you know, when we built
this workout,
my wife and I were homeless.
You were homeless?
Yes.
Did your dad know
you were homeless?
Yes.
I mean, are you estranged
from your Dad?
Uh--
not to ask you
a personal question.
You're not that close to him
is what you're saying.
Not that close,
But now things have seemed
to change a little bit
in a better direction.
(laughs)
Do you have the rights
to use the name Billy Blank jr.
In all manners?
Your dad's not gonna
come out of the woodwork
and say, "look, I'm Billy
Blanks. Forget the junior part."
(laughs)
seriously.
No, I know what you're saying.
It's--It's a legit
legal question, right?
It--it hasn't been an issue.
He knows about this contract.
We have the same agent.
Uh, so it hasn't been
an issue thus far.
Billy, let me, uh, tell you
how I feel.
I think it's great you take
total responsibility
for yourself,
independent of your Dad.
When you get there, it's gonna
feel So much better.
Thank you, Barbara.
And I think you know that.
As a business,
it's not clear to me.
So I'm out.
(mouths word)
(Robert) Billy, look,
I have such respect
for your story,
trying to come out of
the shadow of your Dad.
Thank you.
But as
a value business partner...
Mm-hmm.
You know, I'm not your guy.
I'm out.
All right.
I think you're a great guy,
Billy.
I admire all
the stick-to-Itiveness.
That's good.
But it's not
an investment for me.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out.
Daymond and mark
are Billy's last chance
to make a deal.
(daymond) the beauty
of coming into the tank
is we all are experts
in different areas.
I have a very tight,
strategic relationship
with zumba.
12 million people
do it a week.
And maybe This is
an asset to them.
I would offer...
if mark is willing
to come in with me,
$100,000 for 50%,
contingent on
Billy Blanks name
and zumba's approval
and willing to work with you.
That way, you can get to
12 million people immediately,
tomorrow.
Mark, so are you in?
I'm in.
And that's your offer?
That is my offer.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out,
but Billy has
an offer on the table
from mark and daymond--
$100,000
for 50% of the business
if the established
dance fitness company zumba
will agree to distribute
his brand.
(daymond) So are you in?
I-I love zumba,
But the difference is,
it's just latin style.
So there are guys,
there are people who go,
"Hey, you know. I don't
just want to do latin."
No, I'm not making this
a zumba product.
I'm asking, can this be
"the Billy Blanks jr.
Dance with me"
Through their distribution?
Life is always about
distribution. That's it.
See, I just feel that
I've worked so hard
to create something
that is different.
It's completely different.
(mark)
what he's saying is,
this is a way to
accelerate you very quickly.
Now Billy Blanks jr.
Is making the circuit
through all the zumba classes
and doing the training.
And if we can make it work,
that's a contingency,
you'll get $100,000,
plus 50% of whatever
we're able to sell zumba on.
That's a hell of a deal.
(Robert) Billy,
what's your concern?
I mean, they're taking you
to 12 million people.
I'm thinking you should
be jumping--
It's just because there's--
right now with--
You know, literally,
there are people who go,
"This is the workout
they do with them,"
and--And for me
and my opinion of--
It's a little dis--
Okay, Billy,
I see you're having
a challenge with this.
And what I'm gonna say
is that--
Can I talk to my wife
Real Quick about it?
Sure.
She's here to talk to me.
Yes, because I was
a--I'm about to exit.
So please talk to your wife.
(Robert) talk to your wife.
(Billy) All right.
I don't think he got it.
I don't think
he got it either.
We have one offer
and it's from mark cuban
and from daymond.
I want to ask you about it.
Okay.
Daymond works closely
with zumba.
Okay.
And so they want 50%,
they'll do the $100,000,
But they want to go to zumba
and see if we can be
an extension of their brand.
They said it--they said
they don't understand
why we won't do it
because it brings us
to 12 million--
12 million people,
an audience.
You know we're trying
to separate our brands, so...
but they're saying, you know,
this is a smart deal.
50% of the company.
This--This is difficult,
because you're the brand.
Daymond, why wouldn't zumba just
create their own dance program?
They might. They may say,
"daymond, beat it."
But they don't have the--
him as a brand,
and he does have
brand value.
I love you, sweetheart.
All right.
Love you, too.
See you.
Okay.
♪♪♪
(daymond) Okay, so...
do you accept our offer?
I want to plead
with you guys...
uh-Oh.
I really, truly believe in what
it is that I've built thus far.
I'm willing to bundle in
all my stuff at the 50%.
I'm willing to do that
and to work my behind off,
not bundling it
with another workout,
because they've built
their brand.
And so my purpose is,
I want to build my brand.
I believe in what it is--
It is your brand.
I don't think you get this.
Yeah, Billy, I--
No, I understand that,
but I'm saying,
it's still coming through,
it's--It's building their brand.
No, no, no.
No, it's not building
their brand.
Billy, okay at this point
I'm gonna--
(Billy speaks indistinctly)
at this point,
I'm gonna ask you to trust us.
We're taking you in
to somebody who could
accelerate your brand...
Mm-hmm.
And help you get it in front
of more people
far more quickly than you could
on your--on your own.
We're gonna let you look at it
and say yes or no.
I understand. I just want to be
in the position zumba's in.
I want to be
in that position--
I'm trying to get you there.
(Barbara)
Billy, think of them,
think of zumba
as a delivery boy.
They're delivering your brand
to a whole bunch of customers.
Is it a deal
you would do?
With these two guys?
I would. Yes, I would.
(daymond) Billy, Billy, Billy.
Billy.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Uh...
you know, I don't think
it's the right deal to do.
(gasps)
All right. We wish you
the best, Billy.
Good luck.
Thank you, guys, so much
for having me. Really.
(mark) go get 'em. Seriously.
(Barbara) Good luck to you.
Thank you, guys,
so much.
(Barbara) wow.
I don't think
he quite got it, though.
That's a mistake.
I-I-I'm--I wanna help him
for himself now.
He's killing himself.
Anyways, I'm sending you both
an invoice
for my time on that one.
(Barbara laughs)
Next.
You know what?
If I don't do this,
I'm gonna regret it.
Where are you going?
I'm gonna do the deal.
(laughs)
(woman) Listen...
You know, and I--and I...
guys.
Daymond...
(chuckles)
Sharon?
Sharon Catherine.
How are you?
Why don't we sit down
for a second?
Okay.
Sweetheart.
I've never done this before.
I think that
you don't understand
the opportunity
that we gave you.
Let me explain it
to your wife.
We are offering,
in regards to if zumba
will accept,
if they want to take
"Billy Blanks jr.
Dance with me" program
and distribute it
in their pipeline.
Not making it
a zumba product.
It's exactly like
if you went to walmart
and they said, "We're gonna
put you on this shelf."
You're not pushing walmart.
And if you didn't like
the deal,
then we don't do the deal.
And you're back
to where you are now.
You understand
what I'm saying to you?
I under--I understand.
So this is what I'm trying
to explain to you.
You walked away from
a valuable deal like that,
but a lot of times,
the only thing that is
more important than the number
is the person.
Mm-hmm.
You understand?
I understand.
I wouldn't do that to you
and your lovely wife.
I understand.
Can you reconsider
the deal?
Because you make me
want to help you.
(voice breaking) You don't
realize what this means to us,
that you're coming to us
and taking that extra step.
It means a lot
to me as well.
(crying)
And I-I will definitely
take that deal.
Don't make me cry.
I'm sorry, but I will definitely
take that deal because...
Do not make me cry.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
God bless you.
I will do the best
for you
that I possibly can.
I promise you that.
All right?
(both) Thank you.
I truly appreciate that.
I'm gettin' my sweat
on you. Sorry.
Don't worry about it.
Bye, guys. Thank you.
Tell them thank you.
All right. Will do.
Thank you.
(Sharon Catherine
sniffles)
(cries)
I'm kinda overwhelmed
right now because it's--
I just feel like
it's the road to what we've been
fighting for, my wife and I.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm so grateful,
because I know
there are times in life
where people don't get
second chances.
So I'm grateful for that,
and I just think it's gonna be
a great deal.
♪♪♪